hi it's Matthew Martin from details and
we just finished Milan Show week and
they're a bunch of cool trends you guys
can have to incorporate into your
wardrobe for fall winter 2012-13 and
it's all about the coat coats were
amazing they were dramatic and full and
big coats were long and tailored at
dolce gabbana they were more sporty and
puffy with hoods at Calvin Klein and
shorter and more cropped up we'll take a
Vanetta but I've never seen a season
recently that was so strong in terms of
overall military themes
specifically the omit bin on show for
sure a way to pull this off is you know
look out for shirts and jackets to have
epaulets on the shoulders you want to
have a jacket that's more cropped and
it's double-breasted to have a look
almost of like a cadet jacket with the
buttons running up the center another
cool trend we saw this fall winter where
a lot of printed suits I love the ones
at Calvin that some of them looked at
almost moral but a lot of them were
actually in these really cool colors and
then I'd also really really liked the
ones that Giorgio Armani that looked
like they were different fabrics but
they were actually printed on just a
regular classic wool fabric when we saw
shoes this season shoes were all about a
shine and a lot we're really colorful I
love the colorful options that were in
the loafer forum at Bottega and also
Dolce had some really beautiful shoes
all these friends I've talked about it
really easy to incorporate into your own
wardrobe depending how daring you are
you can go for it in Florida full look
or take bits and pieces of each and
combine them together for a really smart
look for fall winter 2012-13 so now on
to Paris please check out details comm
for more videos of upcoming Paris
collections and you can also follow me
on Twitter at details matter